this is part two of the guide to
secondary gunnery for tanks and infantry
fighting vehicles this video will cover
some Gunung fundamentals such as your
unlocks using an RPG and deciding what
to shoot at I
have a link to part one in the
description and this contains other
important basics such as repairs and
dealing with c4 let's start with the
boys chat
it's highly recommended that you should
actively and verbally communicate with
your driver do you coming on behind
Yanni
you should call it targets threats and
generally communicate your actions and
tactics
bringing up the large map and keep them
informed of what's going on there are
two common but precise ways of
communicating where the threats are
o'clock directions and map call-outs
right
and without voice comms you may be
accidentally left behind if you get out
to repair or be unable to call attention
to important things in time if you're
not on comms do pay attention to your
drivers playstyle on skill up
if you don't want to be left behind
learn to anticipate the drivers actions
based on what he's done before and try
to guess what they're thinking
audio and visual cues get more attention
than text use the Comoros to tell your
driver when you think is a good time to
repair or when he's left you behind
you can also use the 50 Cal to alert
your drivers to important threats though
you know this doesn't always work
I'd also like to talk a little bit about
rocketry or using an engineering
launcher you can use it to help your
driver out against armor firing one
rocket and repairing is more effective
than only repairing but is also riskier
to avoid an explosive death I like to
take my shot right after the enemy tank
fires a shell
you can also hide behind the terrain and
use your drivers ApS
if you do would die however the driver
loses an enormous asset so be careful
the small an RPG often the highest
potential damage but consider and as a
gunner you probably won't have the
luxury of choosing a good angle to shoot
from in this context the MBT law is only
slightly weaker but more reliable plus
it could also lock on to lased targets
this raw can also lock on in highest
high potential damage but it suffers
from poor speed
note that you actually don't have to
wait outside for your launcher to reload
as long as you switch to it before
entering your vehicle your soldier will
finish the reload well inside of the
vehicle
let's talk a bit about loadout as
discussed in part 1 your primary gun is
useful against footsie 4 and rooting out
shy engineers
coming around to the heli
what do you know left
besides it being able to kill fast and
cqb good hip fire and moving spread
stats are also nice to have
longer you take to find the enemy the
more likely that it is he'll be ready
for you
bbws and close-range carbines can bail
you out in such situations
shotguns are quite strong but can be
unreliable
you should bring a repair tool and the
mechanic perk to it but that's pretty
self-explanatory
50 Cal can damaged like vehicles which
include armored cars in the M 140 tool
most of the time however you won't be
able to kill or do it much meaningful
damage if possible do let your driver
handle it and save your heat for
infantry
if the target is important use your
rockets
the 50 Cal is also beat against aircraft
and engaged by aircraft only return fire
if you cannot to repair consider the
present situation before engaging
aircraft or light vehicles is the
chopper also being engaged by friendlies
as you low on health
is he close enough to do meaningful
damage to is stealth a current concern
and are there better things you could be
doing
most importantly when was the last time
you did an area check
shooting Chopra's is fine but it should
be pretty darn low on your list of
priorities
the 50 Cal has a very high spread
increase per shot low velocity animated
damage so your shots need to kill stop
holding down the trigger and get used to
bursting bursting will keep the 50 Cal
lethal at ranges like 50 meters 80
meters even though you can still do
significant damage up to 150 meters if
you microburst carefully like with
aircraft think twice before shooting
targets that you're not confident with
killing consider that the drivers
weapons in Europe air tool are both much
more reliable that brings me to a little
something called belt feeder your airily
going to cool down as you're managing
your verse not mag dumping at bad
targets the better you are the worst
belt theater becomes
as for your optics zoom optics is geared
towards engaging long-range threats and
head glitchers thermal and irnv however
are geared towards acquiring those
threats in the first place
note that irn via thermal can actually
make seen threats harder in sections of
certain maps irnv in particular doesn't
reliable it light up enemies and has a
fairly short range
so here's why I use that Armel optics in
addition to mines it's usually good at
making enemies and messy busy
environments easy to see
it lights people up even at long-range
so for me I don't feel a need for zoom
just choose whatever optic you're
comfortable with though
the proximity scan is a very useful tool
that picks up enemy movement inside of a
small radius in short pulses can be
tricked by enemy's Crouch moving or
staying still most c4 runners will not
be worrying about that they'll just
they're just trying to get as close to
your tank as they possibly can
it's also a wonderful tool for revealing
mines and sneaking locations and warning
you about parachute roses
it's also a general-purpose lifesaver
when you're focused on something else
the gunner's so close if your team isn't
taking advantage of a laser designator
you can also run it to supplement an IFV
driver's toe I don't like the so flam
much you can't watch but while lazing
targets
so flame also comes with a thermal mode
allowing you to run thermal and zoom
optics at the same time
the gunner incendiary is an interesting
tool it drops an incendiary grenade next
to your tank and just like the m34 it
goes through any and all surfaces but
does damage very slowly
which makes it highly and wield against
c4 runners proximity scan and the main
gun is more versatile and just as
effective versus c4 runners
it's also blinding to any thermal or
iron and the optics that you already
driver might be running
useless though it may seem gun or
incendiary can't be useful as an
offensive weapon and we will discuss
that and the next part of this guy part
3 thank you for watching
Oh
[Music]